Islam is in need of a Reformation have
you heard this before yes Islam has
problems so the argument goes but so did
Christianity until the Reformation came
along not only does this position
compare apples with oranges but it
overlooks the little known fact that
what is today called radical Islam is
Believe It or Not a byproduct of the
Reformation of Islam even more shocking
it follows as I will presently
demonstrate the same pattern of
Christianity's Protestant Reformation
much of the confusion has to do with our
understanding of the word reform so
let's start there despite its positive
connotations reform according to most
dictionaries means something like to
make changes in something typically a
social political or economic institution
or practice in order to improve it
synonyms of Reform include make better
amarate and improve these are all
Splendid words yet only because they're
being infused with Western connotations
which are not applicable for Islam
instead Muslim Notions of improving
Society may include purging it of
infidels and their corrupt ways or
executing apostates and blasphemers
Banning many forms of freedoms which are
seen in the west today as products of
long years of Reform from religious
freedom to gender equality can be deemed
an improvement and a betterment of
society from a Muslim Paradigm in short
an Islamic Reformation need not lead to
what western people think of as an
improvement movement and betterment of
society simply because Western peoples
are not Muslims and do not share their
reference points and first premises
reform only sounds good to most
non-muslims because they attribute
Western ideas to the word now let's look
at the Protestant Reformation at its
core it was a revolt against
ecclesiastical Authority and tradition
in the name of scripture in this case
the Bible with the coming of the
printing press increasing numbers of
Christians became better acquainted with
the Bible's contents parts of which they
felt contradicted what the church was
teaching so they broke away protesting
that the only Christian Authority was
scripture alone Sola scriptura Believe
It or Not Islam's Reformation follows
the same logic specifically by
prioritizing scripture over centuries of
tradition and legal debate among Muslim
Scholars but with antithetical results
that reflect the antithetical teachings
of Christianity and
Islam as with Christianity throughout
most of its history Islam scriptures
specifically its pillars the Quran the
literal words of Allah and the Hadith
the words and deeds of Allah's Prophet
Muhammad were inaccessible to the
overwhelming majority of Muslims only a
very few Scholars the literally they who
know were literate and are had
possession of Islam scriptures the
average Muslim knew only the basics of
Islam Five Pillars times have radically
changed no pun intended millions of more
qurans published in Arabic and other
languages are in circulation today
compared to just a century ago millions
of more Muslims are now literate enough
to read and understand the Quran
compared to their medieval ancestors the
Hadith which contains some of the most
intolerant teachings attributed to
Islam's Prophet is now collated and
accessible for free on the internet
where all of Islam's core texts are also
available in dozens of languages and to
anyone with a laptop or smartphone as a
result many of today's Muslims much
better acquainted than their ancestors
with the often black and white words of
their scriptures are protest
against earlier traditions and the
sometimes elastic fetas of the in favor
of scriptural literalism just like their
Christian Protestant counterparts once
did thus if Martin Luther rejected what
he characterized as EXT scriptural
accretions of the church and reformed
Christianity by aligning it strictly
with scripture consider the actions of
Muhammad Abdul wahab whence comes the
word wahhabis who died around 1787 known
as one of Islam's first modern reformers
and certainly a radical in Western
parland he in the words of Bernard Lewis
quote called for a return to the pure
authentic Islam of the prophet and the
rejection of the accessions that had
corrupted it and distorted it that's
from his book in the Middle East page
333 the unadulterated words of God or
Allah in this case are all that matter
for the reformists amongst Muslims the
most upand cominging reformers who
follow the scriptural literalism of
Muhammad Abdul wahab are the salafists
they who care only about what Muhammad
and his earliest followers said and did
as captured in the Quran and the Hadith
now here's the really interesting part
how can Christianity and Islam follow
similar patterns of Reform but with
antithetical results quite simply
because their scriptures are
antithetical to one another this is the
key point one of course totally
unintelligible to postmodern secular
sensibilities which tend to lump all
religious scripture together in a
Melting Pot of relativism without
bothering to evaluate the significance
of their respective words here are just
a few obvious
contradictions the New Testament
preaches peace Brotherly Love tolerance
and forgiveness for All Humans Believers
and non-believers alike conversely the
Quran and Hadith call for war Jihad
against all non-believers until they
either convert accept subjugation and
discrimination or die that's the Quran
95929 Etc then you test prescribes no
punishment for the apostate from
Christianity conversely Islam's Prophet
himself decreed in a canonical Hadith
that quote whoever changes his Islamic
religion kill him unquote the New
Testament teaches monogamy one husband
and one wife thereby dignifying the
woman the Quran allows polygamy up to
four wives and the possession of
Limitless concubines sex slaves the New
Testament discourages lying the Quran
permits it the prophet himself often
deceived others and allowed his
followers to lie including to their
wives in the famous Hadith it is
precisely because Christian scriptural
literalism lends itself to Religious
Freedom tolerance and the Dignity of
women that Western civilization
developed the way it did and it is
precisely because Islamic scriptural
literalism is at odds with the religious
freedom tolerance and the Dignity of
women that Islamic civilization
developed the way it did those in the
west waiting for an Islamic Reformation
along the same lines of the Protestant
Reformation must Embrace two facts first
Islam's Reformation has already been
well on its way and yes along the same
lines of the Protestant Reformation with
a focus on scripture and a disregard for
tradition and clerical Authority and for
similar historical reasons literacy
scriptural dissemination Etc as we've
seen but because the core teachings of
the scriptures of Christianity and Islam
are markedly different Islam's
Reformation has naturally produced a
civilization markedly different from the
West
let's be honest the Islamic Reformation
some in the west are hoping for is
really nothing less than an Islam
without Islam secularization not
Reformation Muslims prioritizing secular
Civic and humanitarian laws over Allah's
laws a Reformation or rather
Enlightenment that would slowly see the
religion of Muhammad go into the dpin of
History such a scenario the demise of
Islam is actually more plausible than
believing that Islam can be true to its
scriptures in any meaningful way and
still peacefully coexist with much less
compliment the modern world the way
Christianity does